my parents loved SNL you know that I am
I feel that first generation of kid
whose parents watched it and so then
you're watching it and being a a Dopey
kid you go I'm going to one day work on
that show did you do any of that kind of
stuff I never thought that I thought you
know I thought I would do comedy but I
never dare I I'm have a very uh it's not
it's not that I have a low self-esteem
but I just kind of thought people who
aimed High were crazy you know what I
mean like I remember you know people who
would say like I'm going to be on SNL
one day I'm like what are you
talking about nobody gets on SNL you
live in New Hampshire you don't get it
be like although the crazy you know the
crazy thing is two people from my
hometown basically Adam s Silverman and
Sarah Silverman yeah so I remember
watching Adam Sandler on Letterman doing
standup in a in on like a TV I got
bought a black and white TV at like a
yard sale and I had it in my bedroom and
I was watching Sandler and I you know I
didn't know him but I knew people who
you know their older siblings knew his
and so I remember seeing him I'm like
well that's that there's not going to be
two of us you know what I mean like
they're the odds and then when Sarah
Silverman made it I'm like well that's
really you know lightning never strikes
a third time um so it is uh it has been
such a lovely trip that uh you know uh
we the three of us have given the uh the
area of you know Southern New Hampshire
a lot to be proud of it's really funny
to me too because I didn't realize when
you tried after for Saturday night you
wanted to be a performer you didn't want
to be the writer you wanted to be you
wanted to be in the cast yes and the
News segment saved you it really did
because uh Lauren saw you as a valuable
writer you still needed to perform and
what a luxury to be on Saturday Night
Live and know that you're going to have
10 minutes at least on camera every
single weekend nobody has it nobody has
nobody else has that when you're on
update you walk around SNL that whole
week and it feels like everyone's
flight's been canceled and you're the
only one who's been rebooked you know
what I mean and everybody and so
everybody has the energy of like waiting
in line at the Delta you know a help
desk because it's just a mad scramble in
an airport where there's no flights
that's what it feels like and at least
when you have update you know well you
know I I don't know I wish you all the
best of luck you know I am going to be
on
TV